all right guys today i'm going to do
both a hardware and software review
on the microsoft wireless
laser mouse
6000 version 2.
so this is the mouse
um the hardware part of it it's not that
interesting really
it's just
a simple
high definition laser mouse
you have
obviously the button
on the top that scrolls uh it's smooth
scrolling it's not notched so you don't
get the sensitive feedback you have to
look at the screen to actually see
how far you're scrolling
um
the left key the right button is i think
it's reversed for you guys but
uh bear with me on the left hand side
it'll look like you're right
on the left hand side we have
a
forward and backward mouse click buttons
so if you're in an internet browser
which i will show you you can
go forward click go backward click
um very simple
on the bottom
you have
the laser is right uh the laser is right
in that hole right there
you will keep the receiver which is
approximately that size uh plugged into
a usb 2.0 port but if you feel the need
to
uh turn the mouse off say you're going
on vacation and you don't need your
mouse plug it right in there it turns
the mouse off
and when the mouse is turned off
it will not use battery power it'll save
a lot of battery life
if you turn the mouse back on
this light will come on
it's a green light right on the front of
the mouse nothing important just lets
you know it has been turned on and it
will work now so i'm going to go ahead
and show you the software part of it um
simple mouse so yeah i'll show you the
software which is much nicer
okay here's the part where i get into
the software basically i'm using my
camstudio screen capture software to
record hopefully hd or high quality
elise so go ahead and click the hq link
or hd link at the bottom of this video
and
i'll be reviewing the software the
software comes with the mouse
unfortunately when i got the mouse
itself
the cd
hold on i'm i'm going to try to show you
the cd that came with it it was actually
cracked so i had to call it microsoft
and they gave me
a link to download the software and the
drivers for so let me get the cd hold on
i couldn't find the cd but you know that
shows you how much i need it i i don't
you can download it anyway if you want
to you don't have to use a cd because
there might be a more modern there might
be an updated version of your firmware
or software for you to use with your
mouse so
if you get a new mouse or you get some
new hardware i recommend you download
the drivers from the manufacturer's
website
and the reason i knew that it was a
microsoft wireless laser mouse 6000
version 2.0 was obviously it was on the
box but it also says it it'll say on the
bottom of the mouse what version you
have and everything
so um
yeah that's it
um so go ahead and enjoy the uh software
part of this
here's the software part of this review
in order to access the customization
software for the particular buttons i
showed you on the mouse
using windows vista's innovative start
menu search feature type in mouse and
hit enter which will select the first
program microsoft mouse
this will bring up your window with
mouse properties
um looks just like microsoft built it in
it's got all these hardware and software
tabs
uh the first thing you can do is program
what the different buttons do if i if i
hover over the left button as you can
see there it is click here so there is
11 the right button wheel
rear thumb and front thumb and that's
exactly where my thumb sits in that
little little
curve right there this is the actual
connected device which i'm using to as
i'm recording this video if i go to the
buttons tab
it's it shows that we're right-handed
which means that the left button is the
primary button
uh double click speed which which
basically dictates how fast you have to
click to open a folder
um so that's how
that's how you can test your
settings
under pointers this is basically what it
looks like um
all the different themes ones working in
the background when it's busy this is
the vista arrow
system scheme all these
is what it comes with
you can change that anyway without the
software
pointer options all the rest of these
things are basically
came with microsoft but the intel point
software is really with the buttons
where you select which microsoft mouse
you have
and then you can program them
accordingly
um
also
hardware
you have to make sure you know which you
have to make sure first of all that your
you can use your touchpad if you still
want to by enabling this one
and if you go to properties
make sure this device is working
properly otherwise you won't be able to
use your laptop without your mouse
so i also have the wireless mouse and
the touchpad
um that's basically it i'll show you
while
say i'm browsing the internet
uploading a video now so i'll open a new
tab and say i search something
and then i
search something else
and i want to go back
i'll just hit my back mouse button you
see my house didn't even move and now
we're searching something again i'll hit
my forward button without even touching
the mouse
searching
whoa okay i guess i accidentally made
that the magnify button
by accident
sorry about that but uh
it's cool feature now you can see
exactly what i'm clicking
so the forward button is a magnifier
interesting and if i hit it again it
demagnifies
it takes a little effort to open it
which is interesting
um
i like it
so um
if you like this software and you like
this hardware matter of fact if you like
this review go ahead and hit that yellow
button next to the video subscribe to my
channel
there will be a ton more coming
so um
yeah i hope you like this video
peace out guys